hey guys Ryan Wright here and tonight
I'm gonna watch the trailer for Call of
Duty advanced warfare I've never
actually played the Call of Duty games
to an extreme level but a lot of people
have been saying this to check this out
I really want to get into Call of Duty I
want to fit in with the rest of the guys
who's left out anyway let's watch this
trailer democracy democracy oh [ __ ]
doesn't video game graphics democracy is
not that these people need hell that's
not even what they want
Wow trying to install democracies and
nations for a century and it hasn't
worked well it's Kevin Spacey these
countries are most basic building blocks
to support Wow looks so cool I want to
be that guy
little things like we ought to be
tolerant of those who disagree with us
we ought to be tolerant those who
worship a different God than us Wow do
you darling Kevin Spacey there makes us
so much coolest art to be able to
disagree with the president audio is
often when you think that you can just
march into these countries based on some
fundamentalist religious principles drop
a few bombs top this cake looks so cool
oh yeah [ __ ] him up
another bad [ __ ] happened
give me a break
people don't want freedom
it's like edge of tomorrow boundaries
rules boundaries [ __ ] bowser's
protection but the president from
themselves
people need a leader who can give them
both the support to you the constraint
to keep chaos at bay
we need a leader you give them that and
they'll follow and that's where I come
in
I wonder who he is
and it looks so good
yeah I got by this [ __ ] game holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] this looks awesome that
just do they look sweet I okay I'll be
the first time in I don't know that much
okay I don't know [ __ ] about Call of
Duty except that it looks cool when you
kill people but that made me really want
to buy the game I always looked at Call
of Duty for gameplay purposes but never
for the story purposes and games that
have story in it I love watching those
way more i'ma play knows way more enough
said watching gonna piss some people off
by singing that Kevin Spacey Nick come
on man you guys gay nothing wrong with
that why are you judging anyway thank
you guys for recommending that if you're
new to the channel subscribe and that's
where I come in
want to get some shout outs here Brandon
wanna see on months senior Brandon uh he
said that he's not going to threaten me
to get a shout out a respectful way of
asking for a shout-out people are
usually threatened me
some people say give me a shout out one
person up subscribed because I didn't
get the Machado at the appropriate
timing and their [ __ ] little life but
Brandon your understanding dick I you
got a good spirit son and I'm sure you
have a big penis
you're gonna pleasure a lot of women
thank your dad for inheriting that
beautiful thing makeup Bren one he
wanted a shout out mega Brent
he's the new Megaman partner that would
be cool
if they made a make like a live-action
Mega Man movie they should [ __ ] do
that now Hollywood listen to me they
used to have a Mega Man song went like
this mega Vega men man Mega Man X I
forgot the rest of it but that was the
coolest part of the song Neng Imran one
seriously you guys have all these names
I just don't get like you hear the real
rejects and you're like no something you
do a film you guys I'm like I don't know
what the mega bren one sounds like I
think from Tron je suis um GI I think
you're missing some letters but your je
suis what is suis mean are you sweet are
you swag swagg doesn't work don't know
why I said that
bad day at homeboy wanted to shout out
such a sweet shout-out to you mother
[ __ ] you know mother [ __ ] is actually
a pretty good compliment if you think
about it you [ __ ] mothers it just
depends on the kind of
there's your [ __ ] and make it okay